COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY JANUARY
ELEVENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER. IN FOR THE
CONVENIENCE OF OUR GUESTS AND
THOSE WHO WATCH THIS THIS IS IN
PART AN ORGANIZATIONAL SESSIONS
WILL COMMUNITIES SYMBOLS
COMMITTEE. AND THEN SECONDARILY
AS THE ASSEMBLY CONTENT OF
JOINT RULES COMMITTEEWE'RE
GOING TO DO A COUPLE DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONAL MATTERS TODAY.
PLEASE BE ADVISED AN AUDIO
VIDEO RECORDING. OF TODAY'S
PROCEDURES BEING MADE AT ALL
AND IT IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED.
HELLO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MR SECRETARY.
HERE AFTER THAT YEAH LARA. YOUR
SON HERE KAMLAGER HERE WE YEAH
LET ME THERE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
YOU'RE ALMOST. YOU HAVE TO WALK
HERE. FOR WE HAVE A QUORUM WE
HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA IS VERY
MOTION ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
BUBER MISTER GIBSON. SURVIVORS
COM LONGER HI MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HI YEAH
CUNNINGHAM RIGHT YEAH- THAT
TIME LARA RIGHT LARA- GIPSON
HI- KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER- WE
MIGHT- HI. THE HOBBIT.
MAIENSCHEIN. THAT MOTION IS
PASSED- SO WE WILL NOW
ADJOURNED THE ASSEMBLY RULES
COMMITTEE MEETING AND WE HEREBY
CAN BE IN THE ASSEMBLY CONTENTS
OF DRUG RULES COMMITTEE- WE
WILL WAIVE TO NEED TO DO THE
ROLE AGAIN WE'RE GOOD OKAY SO
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA IS
ALMOST LIKE A SENATE GENDER.
MOVERS LEVINE SECONDED BY MR
GIPSON OF. MR SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. HI YEAH- I AM
HIGHLY YEAH. RIGHT YEAH HI
LAURA RIGHT ONE FIVE EIGHT
SEVEN FIVE SOMETIMES OUR TIME
HELLO REQUIRED WE- HI GAMES I
BEING FIVE TRYING NOT TO- NOT
AS ALMOST FIVE WELL. RIGHT OR
WRONG. THE MOST OF PASSED OF
ALL THE MEMBERS THE DRIVER
COMMITTEE THANK YOU WELL TO OUR
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE IS HEREBY
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.